five four three two one fire if you
believe the hype this is the future of
city to city transport being tested for
the very first time it hits 70 miles an
hour whisking through 500 feet of a 1600
foot long steel tube the team Hyperloop
one says this short but sweet firing of
a sled in a vacuum tube is the world's
first successful Hyperloop full systems
test the coming-out party for the first
new mode of transportation in over a
hundred years now that's a bit
hyperbolic they're forgetting perhaps
about orbital Rockets practical
helicopters and even hoverboards but
this test in the Nevada desert is a
major milestone maybe giving Hyperloop
one the lead in the race to deliver this
high-speed tubular transportation system
Hyperloop Wan also used the chance to
show off its prototype pod that will
carry the humans or more likely just
cargo at first and that will one day be
propelled through enormous vacuum tube
networks at speeds of up to 700 miles an
hour with close to zero air resistance
to work against it would mean a journey
from LA to San Francisco city centers
would take just 50 minutes door to door
instead of half a day in a car and
there'd be no need to deal with the
hassle of airports Hyperloop Wan didn't
stick its new pod in its tube yet but
instead it used a magnetically levitated
sled which it compares to a
stripped-down
racing car for this first chance to show
all the engineering systems working
together so we've got the levitation and
guidance surfaces the levitation is
magnetic so is the guidance we have the
electromagnetic propulsion which is a
contactless propulsion system that
propels the pod down the tube and then
we have the tube which creates the
vacuum environment and that is allows
the pod to fly down the tube with very
little drag the Hyperloop is another one
of alon Musk's ideas but one that he
decided he didn't have the
to work on himself probably smart
instead groups around the world are
racing to make his concept for reality
either loop transportation technologies
is building capsules and France and
wants to make a system to connect
Slovakia and the Czech Republic or maybe
run through South Korea after a flurry
of bizarre lawsuits were settled ex
Hyperloop one co-founder Brogan BAM
Brogan started a new company a Revo and
it plans to have a Hyperloop up and
running in just three years and let's
not forget that a bunch of talented
students from around the world are
competing to build Hyperloop pods and
test them in a smaller scale tube at
Elon Musk's SpaceX headquarters near Los
Angeles Hyperloop Wan will build its
initial operational system in Dubai the
emirate that likes to be first with
anything new and shiny but it may just
have the vision and the massive amounts
of money that it's going to take to get
this new form of transport up and
running for real
[Music]